NARRATOR:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
The most difficult thing about
wearing Angellift for women
is just to be quiet
for a few minutes.
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
I'm seeking $258,000
for 3%.
Ooh.
That's a problem.
NARRATOR: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
We did
about $3 million retail.
You did $3 million
in sales?
Correct.
Wow.
I'm taking you
way more seriously now.
NARRATOR: ...They're ready to
invest using their own money.
I'll offer you
the $80,000.
I'll lend you $250,000
as debt.
NARRATOR: And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
We really do think we can make
that $5 million.
What kind of greed
is this?
DOUBILET: Don't let
the party hats fool you.
We're savvy
businesswomen.
I could put one match
to the bottom of that.
It would burn beautifully.
You're a gold digger.
I've never heard anybody say
that here in the Shark Tank.
Sheer evil.
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is an entrepreneur
who believes he has a better way
to send a thoughtful gift.
Hello, sharks.
I'm John, and I'm so excited
to introduce to you today
the world's most genuine
online floral solution --
The Bouqs company.
I'm here seeking
an investment of $258,000
in exchange for 3%
of our business.
HERJAVEC:
[ laughs ]
Now, just by way
of introduction,
I'm a Pittsburgh-born guy
who knows how to make
a lot of money, Mr. Wonderful,
selling lovely flowers
to be sent to the
lovely people in our lives.
Lori and Barbara,
these are for you.
GREINER: [ laughs ]
Wow. Man after
my own heart.
CORCORAN:
What a schmoozer.
That's our desperado bouquet,
and this is
our diamonds bouquet.
You know how to suck up to me,
baby, and I love it.
O'LEARY: Are those
real, or are they fake?
GREINER: They're real.
They're beautiful.
Oh, wow.
They smell great.
CUBAN: Are they real?
CORCORAN: Yeah, they're real,
and they're fresh.
TABIS: So,
this business is working
because there are really major
consumer paying points
in this industry.
They say it's $19.99.
You check out at $64.50.
What's up with that?
Bait-and-switch product.
You see a photo.
It's not what arrives.
And this is flowers.
This is supposed to feel good.
There's a solution,
and the solution is Bouqs.
Bouqs are bouquets simplified.
Now, there's three things
that we do
to really make
our business special.
The first --
We have one price.
It's $40 --
$40 including shipping.
There are no "care and handling"
charges.
And we also don't try to sell
you a cheesy plastic butterfly
or some balloons that just
degrades the experience.
The second thing
we do differently
is we ship straight from
eco-friendly, sustainable farms
located on the equator
on the side of a volcano.
Seriously.
That's the volcano.
It also means
you get a really fresh stem,
because it comes
straight from the farm.
The third and final thing
we do differently
is our concierge service.
You can schedule an entire
year's worth of deliveries.
Birthdays, anniversaries,
important business dates --
We take care of it for you,
and we do it all at a discount.
Business is blooming.
Let's get you guys out of
the water and onto the volcano.
Who's with me as we build
the next big flower brand
at the Bouqs company?
Tell us about
the business.
The business is essentially
an e-commerce business.
We launched this business
about 11 months ago.
This year to date,
we've done $700,000 in sales
with almost no
marketing budget.
Wow. Good for you.
What are you attributing
your success to?
I think people were ready
for something that feels
a little different
in this space.
Is this a $40 bouquet,
this bouquet you just gifted me?
That's a $50 bouquet.
I thought you said
you had one price.
$50.
I thought you said
everything was $40.
Everything was $40.
So, our $40 price
is for all of our skus,
and you can double that sku
for $10 more,
and you can triple it
for $10 more than that.
When you say
double the sku --
When you say "double," you mean
double the amount of flowers?
Exactly.
So, if mine is --
That's the most
exciting angle,
and you didn't
even mention that.
It really is.
That's a great angle.
Let -- Let's go back
for a second before we
dive into the numbers.
How did you even
start the business?
TABIS: We started the company,
actually, with my co-founder.
His name's J.P. Montúfar.
He's actually on the volcano,
which is why he couldn't
be here today.
And he's the sort of
floral-farming expert,
and I'm more of the front-end
operations, marketing,
brand side of things.
GREINER: And explain
to us the volcano.
I-I don't know a lot about where
different flowers come from.
At the bottom
of this volcano,
are there a lot of very
prolific floral farms?
Absolutely.
What is your cost
of customer acquisition?
Our average, year-to-date,
is $13.
Yeah?
Last month was 20 bucks.
Wow.
Just give us what data
went into that number.
So, it's a combination
of some really amazing P.R.,
Oprah magazine, dailycandy,
thrillist, Wall Street journal.
How much money have you
spent just on P.R.?
No, not P.R. --
Marketing, advertising.
Total marketing to date
has been...about $70,000.
What does the $40 bouquet
cost you?
We're at 40% to 50% gross
margins on the smallest size.
When we get up
to the triple bouquets,
we're closer to
the 50% end of that range.
Do you ship overnight?
I order today,
it's my husband's birthday
tomorrow.
Do I get them
tomorrow?
We do not.
It is six days
to delivery...
Whoa!
Ooh.
HERJAVEC: Six days?
...From your first
order -- paid order.
Oh, I think you just ran
into a buzzsaw.
John, the average guy
doesn't realize...
Whoa.
...It's his wife's birthday
until that morning.
I understand it. This is --
CORCORAN: [ laughs ]
until she tells him.
How is he gonna
wait six days?
So, two answers
to this question.
One is overnight shipping
launches in three weeks.
We're doing the same exact model
with California farms...
Oh, okay.
...To satisfy
the shorter lead time.
What will the price be
with overnight shipping?
Same prices,
same margins?
$10 more on everything,
slightly lower margins.
Ah.
But aren't you --
So, you're totally changing
your model already.
Um, I don't know
that we're changing it.
It's still farm-fresh,
farm-direct...
You upped the price.
You got --
You have it from California, and
it's going to be $50, actually.
Yes.
Some of our roses will last
in your home three weeks.
Why is that?
And people tweet about that,
people talk about it.
What do you attribute
that to?
So, my co-founder J.P.'s
background in biology
has come in very handy.
We actually have
a proprietary process
that we use
to hydrate the flowers.
And then the other thing is
you're getting these flowers
four or five days
after they were cut.
Whenever you're
at a local florist,
they're,
just by definition,
because it takes so long
for them to get there,
and then they have
to hold that inventory,
just much older flowers.
O'LEARY:
Let's go back to the numbers,
because no one's tackled
what really matters here --
Your evaluation.
My math, I think, is correct at
$8.6 million you're asking for?
That's right.
Okay, so,
let's be pragmatic.
You're going to do $800,000
in this calendar year, right?
We're gonna do
$1.2 million.
And you're going to make
on that about $250,000 pre-tax?
Yes.
Okay.
So, how do I value
your business?
Give me the metrics that
makes you worth $8.6 million.
Sure.
So, the growth
has been astronomical.
We started the business
10 months ago,
and we started
with $13,000
in our total, sort of,
friends-and-family round,
which was
literally, like,
my parents and my sisters
and my best friends.
And we grew that
into $700,000 in sales.
You said you raised $13,000,
friends and family.
Have you raised any money
since then?
We closed a seed round
in may of $1.1 million.
At what valuation?
That was
a $5.2 post money.
To me, that --
That's a huge problem.
I don't like to be
just one of many.
I don't like
to be dumb money.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
HERJAVEC: You just
raised the $1.1 million.
Why are you here
looking for $258,000?
We're actually raising
a full round of $1 million.
O'LEARY: So, you -- You have
an existing round that's open,
and the investors are willing to
pay a 40-times free cash flow.
I'm a very pragmatic
investor.
I don't care
what you're selling.
What matters in business
is cash flow.
That's it.
You're asking me
to pay 40 times,
which would be
the absolute premium
that I would pay
for a much larger company.
But he's growing.
Yeah, b-but it's
a flower business.
GREINER: Your angle -- The thing
that I saw is different...
What's his angle?
Tell me that.
...Was that it's
$40 a bouquet.
That's it. No added charges.
No shipping and handling.
And you can upgrade
for $10 to a $50 bouquet.
My problem is
all your competition
can do exactly what you said
if they like the idea
and the strategy,
so, for me, I think that this
doesn't have an edge anymore
over any other
floral company.
I'm out.
All right, look,
$258,000 for 3%,
I mean, that -- it's such
a small, irrelevant amount
to what
you've already raised.
I-I have a challenge
with that,
and I don't know
if your competitive
advantage
is sustainable.
I'm out.
CORCORAN: I want to address
the name of your business.
I think it's
a terrible name.
It's hard to spell,
hard to remember.
If you gave me
a spelling test,
it would take me 10 times
to really get it.
I'm out.
As usual, all roads
back to Mr. Wonderful.
I tell you, John, there's
one problem with your deal.
You are crazy expensive.
I think the risk in your deal
is not executional risk
'cause it sounds like
you know what you're doing.
It's exit risk.
You have to be acquired
by a strategic.
Very true.
You're in
the Neverland.
You're in a place
where it's not that attractive,
and you didn't really
differentiate yourself
against the commodity
other than to tell me
you're a better marketer.
That may be true,
but I think you may die
of old age waiting to exit.
But there's
another problem.
If I want to send flowers
to your grave,
I have to wait
six days...
[ laughter ]
...And I think --
And I think
you died here today.
I'm out.
Well, I very much appreciate
all of your time
and -- and your input,
and thank you so much
for having me.
Good luck, John.
Thank you
for the flowers.
You're welcome.
Yeah.
Kevin sending flowers
to my grave
was a really funny comment,
but he forgot
that we offer overnight shipping
from California,
so they can show up to my grave
right on time.
[ sighs ]
Brutal.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is a unique way
to solve an age-old problem.
Hi, sharks.
I am Aaron Bruce.
My company is Angellift.
I'm here seeking
a half-million dollars
in exchange
for 10% of my company.
You know,
nobody wants to look old.
In fact,
women spend billions
injecting poisons, acids,
even animal parts
into their face, and that's
just to try and remove wrinkles.
Laugh lines, smile lines,
frown lines, lip lines.
There's all kinds
of names for them.
They all make us look old.
I believe
that we have developed
one of the greatest anti-aging
tools of our generation.
And I'd like to introduce
to you now Angellift.
Angellift is the only
under-the-skin facial
lifting strips in the world.
Through the use
of light, soft pressure,
we can not only stop
this facial movement,
we can restore
facial contours.
We can lift out lines.
We can add volume
to lips.
Angellift is worn exactly like
teeth-whitening strips --
10 to 30 minutes a day,
then you put them away.
They're worn when you're
completely relaxed,
when it's comfortable
for you.
[ laughter ]
The most difficult thing about
wearing Angellift for women
is just to be quiet
for a few minutes.
CORCORAN: Ohh.
CUBAN: Wow.
HERJAVEC: Whoa!
O'LEARY: Clearly...
Do not make any comments.
...We can really use
Angellift up here.
Aaron, you're not
married, obviously.
Well, I am.
This is my beautiful wife,
Kelly.
She's our best model.
Clearly, Angellift is
a game-changer in this industry.
And in many, many cases,
Angellift has been a
life-changer for a lot of women.
I've come here to "Shark Tank"
to find a partner to help me
build an amazing brand.
Does this work
permanently?
This has a cumulative effect
on the skin.
Your mouth, unlike
any other part of your body,
reacts to pressure
and reacts very fast.
We've found out through
orthodontists on our team
that the same thing happens
with braces.
When you put braces on, which
lift two to four millimeters,
you instantly get
almost a facelift,
but months after
they're removed, with adults,
they see the wrinkles
begin to come back.
Really?
But the pressure causes
a cumulative action
within your mouth.
Kelly's gonna hand out
some -- some samples for you.
CUBAN: You guys are both
in your 70s, right?
[ laughter ]
KELLY: Right.
80s. But you're close.
Thanks.
O'LEARY:
Why is it only for women?
It's not. 30% of our --
Of our customers are men.
How much do they sell for,
and what are your total --
Total revenues?
Okay, so, we only sold these
in a test market, all right?
We took an unfinished product,
and we took it
to the smallest live shopping
channel in the country.
In that test market,
we did about $3 million retail.
We profited $1.2 million.
HERJAVEC: You did
$3 million in sales?
In a test. Correct.
Wow.
We pulled out of there,
but we are still filling orders
from shows that happened
over six months ago.
Aaron, you have to wear them
for how long?
30 minutes a day --
30 to an hour a day for 30 days
would take out
about 87%.
So you have
to wear these forever?
No, you have to do
what we call maintenance wear.
So maybe once a week, you'll
wear them once the lines are out
because you'll need to
tell your body
that you still need
that space.
Well, you have pictures here --
Before and afters.
Mm-hmm.
Same model.
These are not retouched.
No.
So how long
a period of time
from the "before"
to the "after" there?
These are 30 days.
30 days.
In 30 days, you had
that much improvement.
That much change.
Wow!
Is there anything
proprietary about it?
We are under patent pending
right now.
Aaron, what do you
sell it for?
So, when we tested it in
the market, we sold it for $49.
Did you mention yet whether you
have any proof that it works?
Real proof.
Absolutely.
Not only do we have third-party
clinical trials to prove it,
but we've gone to QVC,
and they took us to theirs.
So why are you
not on QVC?
We haven't pursued QVC at all
because we want the public
to come to us --
To come to Angellift.
We don't want to
go to new buyers.
Wait.
Aaron, Aaron,
you've done a great job.
That's the one thing
that's very confusing to me.
Yeah,
I'm very confused.
Here's your pitch --
"We have too many sales and have
pulled the product back."
We don't -- I don't believe
the product's finished.
I want a finished line.
That's what I came here for.
So, Aaron,
you want to stop sales
while you perfect
the product?
It's pretty close.
GREINER: But, Aaron,
that's an easy thing to do.
O'LEARY: But that -- Aaron,
that does not make sense.
I know it --
Y-you come in the Shark Tank
with a monster success
that's generating
over $1 million in free cash.
Why wouldn't you
just simply be upgrading --
Constantly upgrading
your site,
constantly upgrading
your package
while you bring in
the cash?
I want to maximize
the value of my company.
We have a product here
that will knock out injections
altogether.
Yeah, but, Aaron, look --
You're talking out of both sides
of your mouth...
[ laughs ]
...Because what you're
saying is,
"I'm taking back control
of my company."
Okay, that's fine.
That makes for
a good talking point.
But you said
you made $1.2 million.
Mm-hmm.
You're not hurting
for cash, right?
Then you come in and say,
"I need $500,000.
I need your expertise."
[ imitates buzzer ]
HERJAVEC: The story
just doesn't add up for me.
To pull a product
that's selling $3 million
because it increases
the value of your business --
You got more guts than I do
'cause I would have --
I would have
kept selling more.
I don't understand
the need.
And if I don't see
the need...
My money doesn't go there.
I'm out.
I appreciate it, Robert.
Thank you.
I don't think you get it,
when you look at this packaging,
what it is.
I think you really
have to demonstrate it.
We --
So it's a very expensive sell
to demonstrate,
do an infomercial, do -- do QVC,
whatever you're gonna do,
but that's necessary.
I think it's gonna cost
way too much money
to make this happen,
so I'm out.
Thank you, Barbara.
Aaron, i-in my world,
it's evil
if something's selling
and you stop doing it.
I've never, ever,
ever heard anybody
say that here
in the Shark Tank.
Sheer evil.
And I don't want to be
part of it. I'm out.
How much cash does
the company have in the bank?
$1 million and change.
Yeah, I mean, look --
I wanted you to be
the first guy at "Shark Tank"
to just own it and say,
"I'm here because I'm gonna
sell a crap load more."
But you just didn't step up
and own it.
I don't trust that you're here
for the right reasons.
I'm out.
So, who's left?
Lori?
Lori's intrigued.
She sees the opportunity,
but she's looking
at the price tag,
saying,
"Wow, that's a lot."
NARRATOR:
Four sharks are out.
Lori is Aaron's last chance
for a deal.
I think
it's a QVC product.
I think it's
an infomercial product.
But I have to admit
i-it's a very confusing story.
You said,
"It was doing great.
"We were on a shopping channel,
and we pulled it.
"We went in to QVC.
They loved it,
but then we didn't pursue it."
'cause he's evil.
GREINER: I feel very iffy
about what you're doing.
I still don't really
understand it.
AARON: Well,
in my opinion, Lori,
this is a giant package in pink
wrapped up for you.
This is your area.
This is your arena.
You're the one
that really carries --
$500,000 for a 10% stake
doesn't do it for me.
I know the offers we've
already had for our company.
I know the kind of sales we do
in a tiny test market.
I know what we're gonna do.
It's huge numbers.
I'm gonna make you
a really hard bargain here.
AARON: Sure.
Ooh.
May not take it.
I want to see
proof of your patent,
proof of the $3 million
in retail that you've done,
and I'd like to see
your clinical trials
and see that
they are accurate.
Those are all easy.
I will offer you
the $500,000,
but I want...
25% of your company.
I respect your offer.
Everything we have going
right now
is so exciting and so big.
I was hoping that you
would jump on and enjoy the ride
and help us with the direction
of the brand,
as I would of any of the sharks,
but it's way too high for us.
Hmm.
Do you want to
counter to her?
I do.
I would offer you 15%.
What kind of greed
is this?
CUBAN: You're just
really proving my point, Aaron,
that you're
a gold digger.
Oh, I am a gold digger.
I'm an entrepreneur.
GREINER: How's this?
If I gave you
the $500,000,
I get 15%, as you said,
but the $500,000
would solely be used
to fund any purchase orders
that came in from QVC.
15%.
15% for $500,000.
You fund the buy from QVC.
The $500,000 goes
into an account
that solely funds
your QVC purchase orders.
Aaron, what are you
gonna do?
Lori, I'll do the deal.
Good.
CUBAN: There you go.
There you go.
Thank you, sharks.
We'll help
straighten up faces.
[ both laugh ]
Thank you, Lori.
When you come back
for an update,
we'll see if I look
any better.
[ chuckles ]
GREINER:
Thank you. Good luck.
Thank you.
If he doesn't have the patent,
if he can't get on QVC,
if he doesn't have the trials,
it's all gone.
HERJAVEC:
Forget all that.
The guy's selling $3 million,
then pulls it?
There's more
to that story.
Yeah, there is.
Next.
NARRATOR: Just this season,
Brian and Julie Whiteman
struck a deal
with Kevin and Mark
for their photo-book service,
Groovebook.
The Groovebook app
allows you to choose
up to 100 photos every month
from your smartphone
and create a beautiful, bound,
photo book in just minutes.
Let's see what they're
up to now.
JULIE:
It's only been a week since we
appeared on "Shark Tank,"
and things have been
non-stop crazy.
BRIAN: We got 50,000
new customers in five days,
and the orders still
keep coming in by the minute.
Yeah?
How's it going today?
Good. Good.
Really busy.
JULIE: It took us one year
to get to 35,000 customers.
One night on "Shark Tank,"
we now have 85,000 customers.
That equates to $3 million
in sales.
But once they tell
their friends and their family,
who knows
what that may turn into?
It could double.
It could triple.
JULIE: Kevin!
Brian, Julie.
We're so excited
to have you here!
O'LEARY: I called
Brian and Julie, and I said,
"Brian, I want to come out
and see the operation."
I want to see
what I'm putting my money into.
Wow.
In all the "Shark Tank"
deals I've done,
I've never seen a tripling
of the user base
in a matter of five days --
None of us have.
This is where we put
the "groove" in the Groovebook.
O'LEARY:
The Groovebook story is proof
of the "Shark Tank" factor.
It's the most powerful
venture-capital firm on Earth.
It has sharks, it has money,
and it has millions
of people watching.
When you put all of those
together, magic happens.
JULIE: Each morning I've
woken up, I've pinched myself.
I just can't believe
this is really happening,
and I just can't wait to see
what happens in the future.
NARRATOR:
Next up is a 19-year-old
with a product he developed
when he was a third-grader.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Ryan from Plano, Texas,
and my company is HangEase.
Today I'm seeking $80,000
in exchange for a 30% stake
in my company.
HangEase is
a collapsible clothing hanger
that'll do two things for you.
First, it'll make it easier
to get your clothes
off the rack.
And second, it'll make it easier
to hang your clothes.
This will save you
time and money
by getting rid
of broken plastic hangers
and stretched-out shirt necks.
HangEase was born out
of my third-grade project
called
the invention convention,
where I was told
to walk through my house,
find a problem, and solve it.
The problem I solved
was right in my own closet --
Broken plastic hangers
and stretched-out shirt necks.
This drives moms nuts.
My third-grade solution
looked like this.
The finished product
looks like this.
You see, the way HangEase works
is simple.
It's built around a hinge
in the center of the hanger
that collapses
when pressure's applied,
dropping the shirt off
into your hand.
It also makes it easier
to hang clothes.
You simply insert the hanger
into the shirt neck, pop it out,
and it's right back up
on the rack,
which I think
is perfect for men
'cause some guys never learn how
to hang their clothes properly.
I sold HangEase
to a major retailer,
but due
to the grueling schedule
of a third-grader,
I wasn't able to continue.
But now I'm here and ready
to bring HangEase back.
Sharks, I'm 19,
I'm out of high school,
so who's with me
to bring a third-grader's dream
back to life?
Let's get you some samples.
Ryan, what
do you do now?
I'm a sophomore at S.M.U.
Thank you.
So you've had this product
in your closet for 10 years?
Yes, seven --
Yes, seven years.
And just decided
to bring it out now?
Yes.
Did you dust
these things off?
Uh, we -- Yeah, we did.
I've had them in boxes.
I use them in my closet,
as well, though, so --
[ chuckles ]
You really had them in boxes
for seven years? Tell me.
I have. Yes.
Well, Ryan,
you said in grade 3,
which was
a long time ago...
Yes.
...You sold it
to a big retailer.
Who was that?
Walmart.
You got this
in Walmart?
And what -- What happened
with those sales?
Well, with Walmart,
we sold about --
It was four --
An order of 400,000 hangers.
So that's about --
400,000 hangers?!
400,000 hangers.
That's about --
[ laughs ] Yes.
How did you even
get in to Walmart?
Well, one of my, uh,
classmates' friends --
I think she was
a sales broker,
and she had
a relationship with them.
Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
One of your classmates'
friends --
One of my classmates' mothers.
Mothers -- Sorry. Sorry, sorry.
So one of your third --
Oh, mothers, okay, there we go.
Oh. Whoa.
One of my classmates'
mothers, right --
Uh, she has a company
that has a relationship
with retailers,
and she had a relationship
with Walmart,
and she was walking through
the invention convention
and saw my product,
and she loved it.
Now, how much of it
did you sell in Walmart?
Their sale was for $200,000.
How much money
did you make?
I made $70,000 off of that.
If it was selling through them
and it was successful,
why wouldn't they
keep going with it?
My suspicion is that it wasn't
really marketed well.
GREINER: What did
one piece sell for?
Uh, they sold for
about $3.89.
All right, so, Ryan --
A hanger? a hanger?
$3.89 apiece?
A four-pack.
A four-pack for $3.89.
So, what do a pack
of regular plastic hangers cost
compared to
a pack of yours?
Like...88 cents.
[ chuckles ]
Did you file
for a patent?
Yes, I have
a fully issued utility patent.
So I have
a big question.
Mm-hmm.
I've seen other products
out there like this.
Really?
I've done research
on a bunch of hangers,
and I haven't
ever seen anything
that does
what my product does.
CORCORAN: You've seen no
foldable hangers at all?
Yeah, I have seen --
I've definitely seen --
N-nothing with
the pressure application.
CUBAN: I think what
Lori's saying, too --
When you buy a hanging bag,
for instance --
Mm-hmm.
Suitcase, hanging bag, right?
You get metal things.
Like, there's a little metal
thing that collapses so that
you can put it --
HERJAVEC: Oh, yeah.
You're right.
GREINER:
Great point, Mark.
Tell me again.
I'm a retailer.
What is the --
What is the benefit, again,
to me,
of using your hanger?
You're selling clothes?
Yeah.
The benefit of this, opposed to
using a normal hanger,
is when people come in
and they try and get
your clothes off to try them on
or they're messing with it
out there --
They just yank it.
It -- It can damage
your clothes.
I'm that guy, right?
[ chuckling ]
You are that guy.
I'm that guy.
Boom, there it is.
There's a sweater
or whatever.
Pull. That's it, right?
Right.
But why does a high-end retailer
care about
tearing clothes off his hangers?
Why would --
Because when idiots like me
pull it off,
they don't want it
to be damaged.
It's a common problem,
though.
No.
I mean, the reason why I've seen
this out there a lot
is because
it's a common problem.
HERJAVEC: Well, look,
I've learned one thing today.
I thought Mark Cuban
was a slob.
I've learned
he's a real slob.
[ chuckles ]
So I don't see the application
for the product.
Um...
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you so much
for your time.
I-I don't think you have
a chance of survival with this
'cause it's too expensive.
I personally do not see
the vision
of this opportunity
at all.
And it bores
the crap out of me.
Oh.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Here's my read on it.
I've invested in a few
businesses on "Shark Tank"
that were businesses put to
the side and then brought back.
On those few businesses,
I've never done well.
And I think because while
you're putting it to the side,
the passion goes with it,
and it's hard to really go back
and travel in time
and kick that product back in
with the same heart in it,
all right?
This is an old idea
that you stuffed in your closet.
You ought to leave it there
and move on.
I'm out.
Okay, thank you so much.
Who's left?
Mark...
And Lori.
...And Lori.
Ryan, who's your primary
competition?
I -- There's
really not anything
that does the pressure thing
out there.
There's nobody else
that you've seen that folds?
I guess the ma--
Right, the major competition
would be the normal
plastic hanger, but --
You've seen nobody
who folds.
I-I haven't.
I haven't. I've --
I've seen this.
I know I've seen it.
Okay.
Now, I'm not sure.
I just can't remember.
Mark said he's seen it.
Definitely in luggage,
I've seen it.
But what about it?
Well, so I'm asking.
I mean, what are we
missing here?
There's got to be
some competition somewhere
that's comparable.
Nothing?
You know what
you're missing here?
You're missing there's
no real problem to solve.
No, I don't believe that at all,
'cause I see --
Look, just being --
I don't mind a kid
with a messy closet.
You have two children,
correct?
Three. Yeah.
Three? It's -- Get their clothes
off the rack like that?
Forget my children.
Me -- Right?
No, literally, I yank. I yank.
Right.
I'm a yanker.
I-I see the value, right?
But it's just
inconceivable to me
that there's nothing else
like this that you've seen.
Or you just haven't
done the work.
It concerns me
that others are out there
really cornering
the market,
I think, using your idea.
And I'm not sure if they
infringe your patent or not.
That's the problem.
Right.
What are you gonna do?
So make a contingency deal
with the kid.
Come on.
CUBAN: Look,
I'll -- I'll make you a deal.
But, to everybody's point,
there is uncertainty relative
to the competition.
Okay.
There is uncertainty
to whether or not
your patent's
being violated.
So, contingent on the patent
being legit and covering
and that we do
have protection,
I'll offer you
the $80,000 for 30%,
just like you've asked.
I know Lori's kind of
thinking about this.
If Lori wants to come in
and split it, that's fine,
uh, because we -- just
two brains are better than one
in this particular case.
Lori?
I would do it with Mark.
I think you deserve a chance.
I-I'd love to do that.
Absolutely.
Done.
All right. Done.
Easy, breezy.
Wow, you could have asked
for a lot more.
Yeah, we could have,
but why?
Thank you, Mark.
I'll even throw in
some Mavs t-tickets
so you can come
to a game.
I'd love it.
[ laughs ]
I'm a huge fan.
Thank you so much.
You're welcome.
I just got to check.
I just got to check this.
Watch.
Yeah.
See, that's great.
Hang one up real fast.
It makes it easy.
That plays. Yeah.
It's great.
I'll just use them at home.
It's worth it.
$80,000 worth of hangers.
[ snaps fingers ]
Nothing.
[ laughs ]
Thank you all.
GREINER: Yeah.
I can't even tell you
how many times
I've pulled down on something
that's on a hanger
and then boomeranged it,
you know.
Right.
LANDIS: I'm feeling awesome.
I've worked really hard
on this product.
It's been a part of me
since third grade,
and I'm crazy excited that I got
a deal with Mark and Lori today
and we can do some great
business together in the future.
[ horn honks ]
I'm Emily Doubilet.
I'm Jessica Holsey.
We're friends living
in Brooklyn, New York.
I've always been
an environmentalist
who loves
to throw parties.
Whoo!
These days, we're living
so much of our lives
behind a computer screen,
but having a party
or an event
makes people come out and
meet each other face-to-face.
We just got picked up
in the Southwest region.
Whoo!
Our company is unique
because we're building a
culture that's a little
weird but a lot of fun.
Bring it in.
We take time out for
a dance break during work,
or even a yoga break
to keep us energized.
Yes!
Purchase order.
Our company is growing
like crazy.
We really need
a capital infusion
to get this party
started.
We've put in
our personal savings,
left stable, paying jobs,
woken up with
panic attacks at night.
We're losing money
quickly,
but there's a light
at the end of the tunnel.
We're so close
to profitability,
and the sharks
can help us get there.
Whoo!
Hi. I'm
Jessica Holsey.
And I'm
Emily Doubilet.
We live in Brooklyn,
New York, and...
TOGETHER:
We're the owners of Susty Party!
We're seeking $250,000
in exchange for 10% of our
party-tableware company.
Parties and events produce
a huge amount of waste.
As an environmental-studies
grad from Oberlin college,
and as an entertainer
at heart,
I've always believed
in order to change the world,
throw a better party.
When I ran into Emily
at -- where else -- a party,
I was looking to leave
my Wall Street job
and put my Harvard
economics degree to use
building a business
that was good for people,
the planet, and profit --
The triple bottom line.
So, Susty -- Short for
"sustainable" -- Party was born.
We've created
a retail line
of eco-friendly,
highly functional,
mix-and-match party tableware,
all made in the U.S.a.
With factories who employ and
empower the visually impaired.
Our products are not
just plain brown or white
like other natural tableware,
but colorful and fun.
The cups, straws,
and cutlery
are made from sustainably
harvested wood,
and the napkins are made
from 100% recycled paper.
Our plates and bowls
are made from tapioca starch
and grass fiber,
but they're super sturdy,
even oven- and microwave-safe.
So, sharks, we're gonna
throw a little party,
right here, right now.
Get up, 'cause
we're gonna party...
Uh-oh.
Susty style!
...Susty style!
[ laughs ]
[ dance music plays ]
O'LEARY: Ahh.
All right!
We have special crowns
for you guys.
Here you are.
CORCORAN: Why not?
We have a special one
for you, Mr. Wonderful.
Is that right?
Why, thank you very much.
Whoo!
I like that.
Ah! That's perfect.
DOUBILET: Can get a little
dance circle going?
Is it a cupcake?
CORCORAN: Mark, you're
the best dancer here.
Come on,
you're so cool dancing.
All right, kiddies.
Come on.
[ both chanting
"Go, Barbara" ]
[ both chanting "Go, Lori" ]
GREINER:
Okay. I'm getting Robert.
HERJAVEC: No, I'm okay,
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Cake supplies.
All right.
That's it?
That was fast.
Cheers. Cheers.
Barbara, here's some
champagne for you.
Oh, thank you.
I earned that.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you.
And we have...
Can I only buy these
from you, or can I buy
from other people?
We contract
a manufacturer.
CORCORAN:
I'm sorry, does that mean
that someone else can order
the same plates
from that particular factory
if they wanted?
We have sales-channel
distribution, like --
Yes. the answer
is yes, right?
CUBAN: So, you're a branding
play, basically.
DOUBILET: Right.
O'LEARY: You want to build
a brand around --
You want to build
a sustainability brand.
Brand design,
and, you know,
we are bringing
a few new products
that are gonna be
the first on the market.
What do your plates cost
for the same amount of plates
that aren't
environmentally conscious?
Our seven-inch plates retail
for about $4.99
for the pack of eight.
A thin paper plate might
be half that price,
but it's not competing.
Our plates are very sturdy,
so we would compare them to,
like, a thick plastic plate.
CUBAN: So, where are you
selling? how's it selling?
Give us the metrics.
We're carried by the largest
natural-products retailer
in the country,
Whole Foods.
So far, this year, we've done
$1 million in sales.
You've got
to be kidding.
That's fantastic!
We're on track
to do $1.5 million
by the end of this year,
which is triple
what we did last year.
CORCORAN:
Good for you. Wow.
Wow. Wasn't expecting
that answer.
I'm taking you
way more seriously now.
Don't let the party hats
fool you.
We're savvy
businesswomen.
[ laughs ]
We've been profitable
for the last three months.
We know we can grow.
From $1.5 million this year,
if we get an investment,
we can expand our sales channels
and expand our product lines
and do $5 million
next year.
So, this year,
with all the slotting fees,
launching nationally, we're
gonna net about an $80,000 loss.
How much cash do you have
in the bank?
We have about $30,000
in the bank right now.
Ooh.
That's a problem.
[ laughs ]
Jessica, how much in inventory
to do have today?
Right now, we have about
$125,000 in inventory.
That's a lot of money
in inventory.
GREINER:
the big interest to me --
You got to move
that inventory, Jessica.
So, you're at negative
current assets.
But we are, however,
on that $5 million that we think
we can get to next year,
we -- we would net
a $600,000 profit.
Jessica, where are you getting
the cash to fund the loss?
We do have some debt that
we've gotten from some angels.
How much?
It's about $200,000 --
A little over $200,000.
I don't want to poop
on the party here,
but you're asking me
for $250,000 for 10%.
You're putting an imputed value
of $2 1/2 million on it.
Do you think, if I wanted
to enter this business in
an identical way...
[ chuckles ]
...That I -- That I could --
CORCORAN: Oh, I can so see you
in this business, Kevin.
There's only happy people
allowed in your business.
Do you think I could do
what you've done
for a lot less
than $2 1/2 million?
No, absolutely not.
We have a few reasons
for you.
No way.
So, one,
we're authentic.
As you can see, we live
and breathe our mission.
What does that mean?
I'm authentic, too.
You're authentic?
Very.
We're responsive. We know
exactly what our customers want.
I'm more responsive.
We listen
to our customers.
[ chuckles ]
My point is, anybody
can do what you're doing.
Would they work as hard as we do
for as little pay as we do?
Would they spend years
researching the market
to know every sustainable
factory and scientist out there?
Maybe, but that's
the problem with your deal.
Would they know exactly what
the Susty Party customers want?
But it's -- It's a huge problem
with your deal.
You've met your match.
Will they show up
at every sales meeting
with a boom box and a glass
of champagne in hand...
Yes, they will!
...Ready to bring
the party,
all while making
our dream a reality?
Good for you. My God.
I love this kid.
More innovation and competitors
are gonna drive us --
Our industry to have more
sustainable materials out there,
and we're gonna be one step
ahead of the competition.
You're selling paper plates,
and you're telling me you're
worth 2 1/2 million bucks?
It's not paper.
Are you nuts?
It's tapioca.
It's not paper.
I could put one match
to the bottom of that.
It would burn beautifully.
Putting Kevin aside
for a sec --
And he is bringing up
a legitimate point --
Why is the business worth
$2 1/2 million?
We're gonna do $1.5 million
in sales this year.
On which you're gonna
lose $80,000.
But we really do think
we can make that $5 million.
And why would we believe
that you could actually build
the business
from where it is now
to $5 million
one year from today?
So, we're introducing
38 new product skus.
Without purchase orders?
Uh, yeah, we're --
We're kind of coming up
with a plan for that.
You love to talk,
and you're delicious
to listen to, no doubt.
I could spend a whole day
and enjoy every minute.
But I just don't think
I'm ever going to make
my money back on this.
I'm out.
Emily, the designs
are fantastic,
but...you got to run
like heck.
You got to get market share
above the $5 million level,
and hopefully,
somebody acquires you.
Or you then scale back
and then start making a profit.
I see a tremendous
amount of risk
in the business
at this point.
I'm out.
You know, you guys
are a great team.
I personally like
environmentally
conscious products,
and I like that it's made
in the U.S.a.
That's great.
More jobs for Americans.
I would love
to have invested in you,
but I just recently invested
in a company that makes
gift bags and tissue
and things like that,
and I think they're going to be
getting into plates that
are environmentally conscious,
so, for that reason,
I'm out.
The problem with your deal --
And I think the other sharks
are starting
to circle these waters --
This is a total commodity
that you're basically curating.
Frisky over here is very good
at picking the right colors
to put on the commodity.
GREINER:
"Frisky" is a positive.
I'll -- I'll take it.
So, leaving aside
your valuation issue,
the risk is
that someone else does this
that already has a much bigger
distribution channel
and a bigger
marketing budget
and crushes you like
the frisky cockroaches you are
in this space right now.
Everything you're doing
anybody else can get,
which is why I believe your
investors have only put debt in,
not equity.
We strategically
took debt
because we didn't want to give
up ownership of our company.
What interest rate
are you paying on your debt?
Some of them are as low as 4%,
and some are as high as 10%.
I sense that there's a difficult
situation coming, here.
Just -- I'm
a balance-sheet guy.
I'm looking at what's happening.
You're growing. You need cash.
Here's an offer for you.
NARRATOR: Three sharks are out,
but Kevin seems interested.
Here's an offer for you.
I'll lend you $250,000
as debt at 10%,
which is what
you're paying somebody else,
and I want...
30% of the company.
Plus the debt?
Plus the debt.
CUBAN:
[ laughs ]
[ groans ]
Bam!
We're --
Well, it's the only offer
you've got.
Boom goes the dynamite.
It's the only offer
you have.
So, Emily,
three sharks are out.
You have Mark left,
and Kevin's made you an offer.
Yeah, guys, I'm concerned
about your management.
Operational efficiency
is everything for you guys
when you're
cash-constrained.
You have $125,000
in inventory,
and what raises
a management red flag --
While you still have
this huge amount of inventory,
you're introducing
more skus.
We've come this far with
only $300,000 in capital. um --
No, no, no. don't -- don't
give me the sob story...
I'm not gonna give you
a sob story.
...Because it's not about
how much you've raised,
and it's not
about your sales.
Right.
It's about how effectively
you've managed your cash...
Right.
...How effectively have
you managed your inventory.
Right.
Look, I like the business,
but, operationally,
cash-management-wise,
there's, you know,
a truck on the other side
of the tunnel,
coming straight at you.
The minute one of these --
You -- retailers says,
"You need to start
generating demand,"
or a competitor
comes in the market,
you're stuck,
and that's a red flag for me,
and for those reasons,
I'm out.
Hey, there.
Hi.
All roads lead
back to Mr. Wonderful.
To Mr. Wonderful.
[ laughs ]
What are you gonna do?
You know, I am the only shark
that actually graduated with
an environmental-studies degree.
Had you done your research,
you would have learned that.
I am an eco-preneur
for profit,
so I think profit
saves the world.
You're talking to
the only person here who cares.
[ laughs ]
I don't think it's
a good deal.
I think
we can do better.
So make a counter.
Well, what -- You know,
what if you did $250,000 in debt
and an option
for $250,000 at a discount
when we do
go out and raise money,
which, inevitably,
we have to do?
No.
I'm very good
at helping entrepreneurs,
but I see no reason
to be flexible here.
You are about to hit
a brick wall.
You both know it.
Well...
A little more champagne
while you're thinking about it?
You got to come
to a conclusion.
Right.
We think
that we can go out
and find an investor
who will support us.
All right, ladies.
The party's over.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Go get 'em.
Good luck.
Bye.
Eh. Blah.
DOUBILET: We turned
down Kevin's offer
because we're not willing
to give up so much equity
at such an early stage.
We're just gonna keep
living by our motto --
Respect Earth
and party on.